did you ever find a group of people
that you get that get you
yes is that what producing is
essentially is you tried to find the
moments when you just get each other
no um
i would say
they're definitely uh
certain artists with certain
temperaments
when you're around them it feels like
you can finish each other's sentences
you know just see the world the same way
comedians as well
um and that's not essential
for
the the two of you together creating
something special no
so it could be attention to
it could be anything it could be any
there's no rules it's um it'd be like uh
think of it like a coach
a coach could
a coach could bring their what they have
to bring to any talented individual and
you know help them
find their way
um
and sometimes the right you know the
right coach for the right athlete really
works and other times there's a mismatch
have you seen the movie whiplash
i did i saw it when it came out so i
don't really remember it well but i did
see it so there's a coach type of figure
yes who is pushing a drummer
to create to grow as a musician but also
to create something special i don't know
if it's even special music skill-wise
it's a special moment yeah i don't know
what he's trying to create now from one
perspective it's just an abusive a
person who selfishly gets off on being
abusive to those he's with but from
another perspective the way i saw that
movie
is it's just the two
right humans finding each other at the
right moment in life and risking
destroying each other in the process but
maybe something
beautiful will come of it
do you think uh that's a toxic
relationship
or is there
does some of that movie resonate with
you as that sometimes is required to
create art
that
that kind of stuff yeah it doesn't it
well there's suffering involved but not
that kind of suffering
um
not for me there's some there's some
people who that's their process and
that's
whatever works you know there's no there
are no right answers for anything
involved in art it's we're all
trying experiments to find a way and
even for the things that i work on i
don't have a set way that i do anything
every i come to every project
blank
and um
see
i really listen to what the artist plays
and says
and through what they're through what
they
explain
they want to do
um
help find the best way to get there
um was it implicit in the movie
that the uh the mean teacher liked being
a mean teacher
you said the way you described it was
that he got off on treating people this
way do we know that to be the case i
don't remember that in the movie but we
sometimes project that onto people
people who are
really rough on students
you start to think well maybe
maybe that is fundamentally who they are
and if it's fundamentally who they are
that there must be some pleasure in it
or it's an addiction of some sort
but it could be
also
a deliberate choice made by the teacher
it also could be a lineage like you know
in in the zen tradition
there are sort of the
the the
the mean roshi's
who if you do something wrong
take a physical action
and um
it's just in the lineage it's considered
that's how you teach
um
i i didn't come from that lineage so i'm
i'm much more of a i feel like it's more
of a
collaboration between
people working together to make the best
thing it's not a
it's not a boss
slave relationship at all it's much more
of a
let's find our way and and we agree at
the beginning of the
process that if either of us
or any of us
don't like what's happening we say it
and the goal is to keep working until we
get to a point where we we're all really
happy with it
it's like if if we make something that
an artist likes and i don't like or if
that i like and they don't like we
haven't gone far enough
in terms of lineage the ones that seek
destruction and the ones that seek
happiness all come from the same lineage
we all came from fish so
somewhere in you
deep down there there's the other stuff
too
it's just that you haven't been uh
yet by the way because you said every
new project including maybe starting
today
uh
is an opportunity to channel to plug
into something
that was always there and you haven't
gotten a chance to plug into
you